good morning everyone i am jeff
blankenberg and as we do most
thursdays uh welcome to alexa and
friends today i have the good fortune
of joining with joining me daniel marcu
from the alexa ai organization thank you
for being here daniel
hello thank you for having me certainly
so um as most of our guests most of the
people that tune in and watch this show
regularly
no i like to start our episodes with
kind of some
some silly peculiar questions they i
think they help people understand
who you are a little bit as a person and
as
as i tell everybody you've not been
prepared for these questions so
um you don't really have answers
prepared and that's okay i think that's
part of the
the fun of this but it's also an
opportunity for people to get to know
you the person
not just you the scientist right all
right
all right so the first question that i'd
like to ask you is
um if you could have one superpower
just one like you can't be superman
that's a lot of superpowers
but if you could just have one
superpower which one would you pick
i i wouldn't choose one
um you would i
and the reason i wouldn't choose one is
i mean just think about yourself or
myself let's say at some point maybe
one superpower was that i would like to
know how to drive a car
but then once i learned how to drive a
car it was no longer such a big deal
okay i think at least for me the the the
more interesting part
would be i would be interested in
working on developing a superpower
but i don't think i would just
want to have a superpower hand it over
to me oh wow that's
maybe it's too much power what
what okay so let's let's flip that
around then so if you don't want to just
have one assigned to you what if
what if it was like most of things in
life right if you if you spend
two three thousand hours practicing
something
then you become like an expert at it
right you become someone that's very
proficient at it what if you had to earn
it that way
and uh and like there was something you
could just really refine your abilities
uh by practicing and really focusing on
is there something then that might
appeal to you
well i think there are lots of things
that appeal to me on that front maybe
i would like to be a better um
climber uh mountain climber uh to really
get to the top of mount everest one day
but
not not just for the sake of it not
about the top of mount everest but
let's say to get to places that are less
accessible
uh so that i can see more wow
uh i would like that too that would be
excellent
that would be on the list maybe playing
a
guitar better than i play that sort of
stuff
i play guitar very poorly uh and i don't
think any amount of practice is going to
change that but that's okay
uh all right so speaking of guitar this
is a good lead in
let's pretend for a moment that you have
a
uh a band you're in you're in a musical
band
uh maybe a rock band sounds good yeah
that sounds
actually it's great right when i when i
was doing my phd i thought at some point
that
the ideal lifestyle for me would be to
do research during the day and play in a
rock band in the evening wow all right
we hit a nerve here that's good
you're on the good track excellent
excellent okay so you've got this band
you're the leader of the band
and you guys are sitting around deciding
you've got all these songs and you want
to decide
what the name of your first album is
gonna be
what would you name your first album
first album um
let me let me walk from maybe
one one one song that i like a lot or
let's say a
rock song that gets me going every every
single time i hear it okay
so every single time for example i hear
uh bon jovi it's my life doesn't matter
whether i'm happy or whether i'm
completely tired it just bumps me
that is a good one that'll get the heart
pumping that's a good one
i love the song i love the lyrics i love
the video
that comes with it so i think it's it's
very inspirational to me
and i think the the reason it's
inspirational it has
lots of zest for life so uh
if i was to choose a an album the title
probably would be something
along those lines so i like to do
things with zest and i like to
completely immerse myself in in what i'm
doing so maybe
immersions or journeys because i do
think that uh it's fun to
kind of change once in a while
everything that you do and
uh over and immerse yourself in in
something else so maybe
journeys or immersions or something
along those lines all right cool that's
a good answer i like that it's a good
reflection of who you are
um all right i like that okay so last
question this is always the last
question
um and i i really i'm i'm always curious
in the why
of this answer more than i am your
actual answer but the question is would
you rather
if you were if you were forced to choose
uh
would you rather have to fight one
horse-sized duck or
100 duck-sized horses
one horse-sized duck versus a hundred
oh i would i would rather fight the the
the
the one the one big one so what's your
reasoning for that how did you decide
i think it's uh it's much easier you
you kind of learn
much easier what the strength and
weaknesses of that
horse-sized duck is and the
device uh strategy is easier for
fighting the duck
i think it's it's definitely a much
easier task putting up with a hundred
ducks
yeah i think a hundred tiny horses would
be would be pretty challenging
imagine being surrounded by a hundred
ducks that would be scary
a hundred tiny horses would be a little
bit overwhelming
but with the one size or one horse size
the duck
i would be comfortable uh
all right so all right so i like that i
feel the same way i
i often imagine what it would be like i
feel like it would be very majestic
to ride a horse-sized duck i feel like i
could imagine myself in like
revolutionary war
garb like with a sword charging into
battle riding uh writing a giant duck i
think that would be pretty cool
closer the closer that comes to that is
riding an ostrich yeah right
yeah yeah but have you tried it but i'm
hoping just by scaling up a duck it can
still fly
because ostriches obviously are land
bound but
man if a duck that size could also fly
we got something that's uh that would be
a lot of fun
okay so uh let's get let's get into some
seriousness
uh one of the things that i really like
to share with people when we have guests
on this show
is to help them understand kind of
who you are what your titling your role
is here at amazon
on the alexa team and then a quick
kind of journey through how you got here
i know for me
i didn't i didn't go to school to do
things with voice or natural language
understanding or even ai
um i actually have a degree in
psychology but i was really good at
software development and i found my path
that way
instead through my career uh and i find
that that's true for a lot of people
there are a lot of people involved in
voice that
they don't have a naturally obvious
educational path or even early career
that got them here
and i think yours is probably a bit more
traditional maybe what we would have
expected
but i'd love for you to share first kind
of what your role is at amazon and then
how you got here yeah so i'm a director
in the alexa
ai organization and my
the job the way i think about my job is
to
make alexa smarter as it can when it as
it comes to
alexa understanding and dealing with the
information needs
of customers and how did i get here
so i uh i was born in romania
and i did my undergraduate studies there
and at some point um
i think i was uh in the third or fourth
year of my undergrad uh i was
in the library just browsing through
journals that were at that time maybe 15
20 years old because
the internet was not invented yet and
the library in a communist state did not
have access to the latest journal so
these were
these were journals from the 70s and as
i was browsing through journals just to
see what
are considered in or were considered
interesting topics in the 70s
i came across an article that was
written by
bill woods in the communication of acm
and that article talked about how you
can
build a natural language interface to a
database
so the idea was that you ask a question
in natural language and
some magic happens and you get back the
answer from from the database
and when i came across that article i
was just
blown away just by the idea that you can
build
computer systems that handle natural
language that
like people so at the time i like
mathematics i like computers so then i
said to myself
that's it that's what i'm going to do
with my
so um so then i i went from uh
from that to um actually building the
translation system for my
graduation project so i built an english
ukrainian
translation system and then i went to
university of toronto in canada and i
did a master's and a phd there
and then in natural language and then i
took a job at
the information sciences institute to
the university of southern california
and i
became a researcher there and
continued to do research in quite a few
areas in the natural language processing
field
um i also at some point
started a company that language weaver
that was the first company that
commercialized the statistical machine
translation software that was a time
when
statistical approaches to natural
language were let's say
uh revolutionizing the world yeah no
longer
now it's neural systems um and then
kind of found myself splitting time
between the university
the company grew that company got it
it eventually got acquired um
spend the time with some time with the
acquirer went back to the university
and in the towards the end of 2016
came to amazon oh very good so you you
and i got here about the same time i
joined
uh i i just hit my four-year anniversary
uh two weeks ago
so you must have been just about the
same time yeah so i started in december
so
uh in december i'll be very good four
years very good i'm
very good well i'm glad you're here um
okay so so you so you ended up going
from romania to toronto
um how was uh
i mean it sounds to me like you did a
lot of very interesting things uh
some some interesting work certainly for
your phd certainly as part of that
company that you started
do do any of those things still live on
is there any like work that you've done
early in your career that you can still
say like
oh yeah some of my work still sits over
there or this product is using something
that i put together
i think um some of the
some of the ideas have been
let's say adopted or transitioned but in
different forms uh in uh
even in products that are used today or
in in techniques that are used today
and but the field of natural language
has underwent maybe two revolutions
since i started so first it went from uh
using uh knowledge-based approaches to
natural language to using statistical
techniques
then move from statistical techniques to
uh neural techniques so in that process
what typically when you when you go
through those uh
science revolutions as a kuhn calls them
for example uh
what what survives is not so much the
methods but some of the
core ideas behind those methods
so it is typically at that level that
things have survived
not the particular approaches got it got
it got it okay
so what was the if you had to identify
something that was kind of the main draw
for
coming to alexa right i mean you said
you'd been jumping between your own
company
and uh certainly academia what was the
what was the draw to be able to come
here and to be able to
um work on a project like this is there
anything that stood out to you as like
oh that's something that i really want
to address
i think the the for me is the
what what really attracted me to alexa
and to amazon
in general is the opportunity to
do research that has such a
broad customer impact i in the past i
did quite a bit of research in an
academic setting and
figured out how to do that well i think
and then also i figured out at some
point
i mentioned at some point that i kind of
liked journeys right and i had that
part of my uh career was very
academically focused and
uh i was focusing then on
just how to write as as many good papers
and publish as many good papers as i
could every single year and do research
in as many research areas as possible
and that was super super exciting
um but at some point i thought that was
no longer that exciting what became more
exciting was to figure out how to build
a company from scratch with friends and
colleagues and
partners business partners and how to do
science in support of that right and
because i
and and it had to be some company that
also had a strong
science component in it if it didn't
have a science
facet that would have not been exciting
enough
but to figure out how to do science in
the context of a startup and then also
in the context of let's say medium-sized
company
uh was super interesting
but i've never had the opportunity to
do science in a company that has the
footprint and the customer base that
amazon has and i thought that i can
learn
a few things in the process if i was to
work for
for amazon so that reason i ended up at
amazon
and i think the the second reason is uh
if you look historically at the way
different
fields have evolved
at some point when certain fields
scientific fields become a little bit
more mature
i think more interesting research is
happening in the industry so
initially lots of the research let's say
in databases for example we talked about
that in the beginning
initially lots of the interesting work
in databases have happened in the
academia
but at some point i think that
most of the interesting work in
databases became driven by the
commercial sector when that became
[Music]
something that hundreds of millions or
billions of people
could put to good use and i think the
natural language field
has gone through a similar
transformation so definitely when i
started my
phd in natural language processing it
was purely
a passion-driven enterprise i just
loved natural language and i thought
that getting computers to understand and
deal with language in a way that
people do would be the most fun thing to
spend my time on
but nobody cared about it in the
industry at that time
right now that's no longer the case i
think today
the there is more research
good research uh and and the the field
of natural language processing is
advanced much more
in the context of of uh
in the commercial sector than in
academia got it
oh that no that's very interesting do
you do you think that there's a there
was a tipping point that happened
i know that um you know probably
eight eight or so years ago there was a
moment where all of a sudden we
we had kind of crested this this
recognition ability of natural language
understanding and a number of other
things that made it
really possible for things like alexa to
happen right
i mean we've had the ability with
computers to be able to recognize speech
for
decades but it was always a very limited
vocabulary i know that there were
some folks that i talked with that you
know they were building um
they were building systems in the 80s
that would let people like
vote for the the class president um but
it could only really recognize
two terms right that was that was the
extent of it you couldn't say
anything like we do with alexa today uh
has there
was there a moment that you can identify
that kind of like
highlights why there's so much research
and voice and why it's become so
important
i i think it's uh it's been a
accumulation of many many years of
investments and i have to credit the
the us government for uh being
behind the investment in voice and in
natural language technologies for
for so many years for decades at times
when
everyone else thought that that would be
a
lost cause and i think that that
that funding that the us government has
put into
many academic institutions at that time
to just continuously raise the bar and
continuously
or transition let's say from speech
systems let's say recognizing
maybe a handful of words to them maybe
recognizing continuous speech but for
very small vocabularies and eventually
getting to where they are today
and the same thing for machine
translation the same thing for
information retrieval systems so
i think that it it took essentially
that investment started in in the 50s in
the 60s kind of
took a downturn it it almost came to a
halt in the 70s it was
uh rehabilitated and
but it took from the 70s to let's say
early
2010 or so to get to the point where
we or amazon let's say felt comfortable
to say well i think the time is
right maybe we can bridge the gap
between where the technology was at the
time when alexa
was the project on paper to the point
where
it became a reality and it launched as a
product but i think it's the
outcome of not just one uh
one let's say innovation but it's more
the result of
40 years of investment in the natural
language processing area and speech
recognition that's good to know i don't
think a lot of people realize i mean
alexa's obviously been around
for five or six years now um and i don't
think a lot of people realize just how
long
the tale of the research that led to the
capabilities that we have today
uh has really taken right it's it's not
as if someone had an idea in 2014 and
they're like
you know this is something we should try
no one's ever done this before it's
obviously been something that's been
going on for
a very long time longer than my lifetime
actually um yeah
it's great that's why i think
it's super interesting to
do research at the cutting edge of
science
because i think when you do
that um and sorry and in a commercial
setting because i think when you
when you do that um it's
uh it's not only a question about what
paper can i publish
next let's also continuous
let's say a search for figuring out
what customer capabilities
are possible to develop given the
current state of technology
and then uh it's it's a
there's quite a bit of innovation that
happens not only from the perspective of
advancing the state of the art in some
particular technique
but it's also i think lots of innovation
that has to happen
in terms of bridging the gap between
some existing customer need or some need
that customers don't even have
an idea yet so that they have that need
like it was the case for alexa right
and then doing the science that is
needed in order to
get to delivering on that customer very
cool
okay so so you uh we we talked about
toronto but you also mentioned that you
were at usc for a while for a long while
actually
and i'd love to know this is one of
those things that i don't have an
opportunity
um to really reflect back on because i
i i did all of my research and education
in psychology right so
i really spent a lot of time thinking
about how humans think which actually
applies very well to what i do today but
when i was back there and i was thinking
about
um the research that i was doing in
psychology almost none of that applies
like none of the lessons that i really
gained from that
apply greatly to what i do today because
i've pursued this path of being a
software developer my my whole career
but i would imagine someone that has
been in academia for a good portion of
their career
uh and then you come here there's got to
be some experiences or some learnings or
something that you've gained as a part
of that world as part of that research
world
that you find yourself able to apply
here at amazon is there is there any
interesting
stories or learnings that you have from
that
for sure and i'm very grateful for tons
of things that i learned
while i was at usc and at isi in
particular the information sciences
institute
let me say that when i graduated with a
phd from university of toronto
i think i had a very limited
understanding of how the world operates
and i just imagined that if i
uh that my job is simply to
write science papers and advance the
state of the art
and i did not have any
uh let's say the connection between that
and where is the funding coming from
right that was a complete mystery it
kind of did not enter my
uh uh it was not part of my thinking and
which i think is actually what it's sure
yeah that's a good problem to have i
i have many friends that are in academia
that most of most of their own personal
income is tied to grants and a bunch of
other stuff that they really have to
work out so
not worrying about the money and just
being able to do the research sounds
great
yeah so i think and i think that's what
students should do right they should not
have any worries over the
students should when you do a phd you
should have the freedom to explore
whatever area that
you want and to go in whatever direction
your passion takes you which is
definitely what i did for my own phd
but but going back to lessons that i
learned from
from usc i think the first thing that
i learned was to be entrepreneurial to
be self-sufficient
so initial when i when i got there i was
kind of shocked
to learn that geez somebody i need to
figure out the way to
pay my salary so information sciences
institute was a soft money institution
so you have to generate research grants
in order to pay the salary and
obviously when i joined somebody was
doing that for me
and that made me profoundly
uncomfortable i did not feel comfortable
to
depend on the ability of somebody else
to write grant proposals and to fund my
research
because i felt that there is quite a bit
of a disconnect there so
i can do i was thinking i can do the
best research but if that person
misrepresents my research or doesn't do
a good job as a
fundraiser then then what uh
and um so i i think that uh
the first the first thing that i wanted
to learn was how to become
self-sufficient which is how to generate
enough ideas
and deliver enough value to justify my
own salary and the salary of the people
that
work for the lesson so i think and
i continue to be i think entrepreneurial
and
and try to stay self-sufficient and
always function with that
in mind thinking that nothing comes for
free in some sense that
you need to to make sure that you create
sufficient value
uh with whatever you do i think the
um uh second important lesson was that
um or the the other
super important thing that i learned was
that i it's a good idea to have a very
high bar
on science and but in general on the
people that you work with
i learned that you do not need a hundred
people you do not need a thousand people
to become or to to become the world
leader in a particular
field so i think with the group of
five ten people you can really take
an area like speech recognition or
machine translation or
you name it and if those 10 people are
the
right sort of people that group can
become the world leader in in that
particular field
um and yes it's way more complicated to
go from that
to let's say building products and all
that but
i learned that surrounding myself
with the awesome people that know more
than me
and learning from them
and just being having a high bar
uh on that uh is probably
one of the biggest let's say uh drivers
or or
uh of success than anything else
so that's definitely something that i
also took to amazon when i came here
it's good yeah
and i think you see that here uh we
often refer them as
as two pizza teams right uh the idea
that uh and that's something that a lot
of people may be watching may have not
heard that's an amazon term i think
but the idea of a two pizza team is that
if you're working on a problem
you shouldn't have more people on
working on the problem than two pizzas
can feed
right and i i think that's a really good
philosophy because you really just want
to get the key stakeholders the key
players
and adding more bodies doesn't solve
more problems
absolutely and i think maybe also
aligned to that
i learned that focus matters so
initially i was
very uh let's say broad
in my approaches and i was trying to
solve problems in
as many places as possible and advance
the state of the art
in some sense indiscriminately or
opportunistically if you if you want so
i would see something that i i thought i
could do better and i
was doing that and then here and there
and there and
a little by little i learned that it's
better to do
one thing super super well than doing
10 things just mediocre well yeah
the later a friend of mine
said this or summarized that very nicely
he said well
this is like physics it's pounds per
square inch right so
the smaller the surface area that you
focus on if you apply the same force
it's
the likely the impact the the higher the
impact
so i think that's a good summary so
focus i think it's also super important
which is again something that
um is equally important now in the
context of amazon sure
for sure for sure okay so um there is an
event kdd 2020 going on this week
uh and i know we wanted to make sure
that we we mentioned that that's going
on
but i think it also gives us a good
opportunity to kind of talk about
knowledge discovery um and information
retrieval
and things along those lines so those
are the things that your team focuses on
can you tell us
more about what your team is doing and
what you're working on
sure so my my team is focusing on
enabling the conversation centric
question answering capabilities on any
alexa devices and supported languages
for customers that have some information
needs
and the focus of my team is on
unstructured data
so customer find
will find that alexa responds to their
questions in
different ways and my team
at the moment is helping alexa customers
in three very concrete ways so
for example alexa can answer individual
something that we call factoid questions
uh using unstructured data
so like quoting from some narrative
source so if you ask the question like
what is an ostrich uh it's
uh you would get the cohesive response
that is
on drawn from some unstructured data
that is available on the public web
so putting into place all the techniques
that enable
those responses to be generated and
building the service and doing the
science and continuously improving that
service
is part of what my team is doing
the second capability is in some
contexts maybe
you're looking for uh if you have a more
open-ended question like what's going on
with the
election for example um
maybe just a short answer will not do it
sure right so in
that instance what we do is we look at
new sources such as reuters for example
and we figure out how to provide
an answer a summary that is a little bit
longer it's just not one
uh it's not just one short sentence but
it's a little bit longer and because
there's quite a bit going
on and the third thing that
we've been working on is trying to
transition
alexa from just answering the question
to engaging or helping customers engage
in longer dialogues so
if you ask the question like
what's uh what's the population of
louisiana
for example you may get the answer but
in
the context of today's events maybe
you wouldn't mind if alexa would come
back to you and say
um hey um would you like to
hear the latest news of hurricane
laura or the impact of hurricane laura
on louisiana because that's something
timely
and some customers may like to get to
that information
it expresses that like i've already
expressed my interest in louisiana
but you know just by asking for the
population so i clearly have an interest
in that region i think that makes a lot
of sense
so so those are the the three customer
experiences or services that
my team has developed in the context of
alexa
and of course uh
they're never a done deal right so
how to continue to improve those
experiences and how you create
how you can make them uh better and
better for the customers that's a
continuous focus in the team all right
so
i have a follow-up question to that and
this is just something that's
interesting to me because
again as a developer somebody that's
built lots of things for alexa
i find that i'm i'm always clamoring
for structured data right i want a data
source that just has the information
that i need
in an easy queryable fashion uh and i
wish that i had that thing
so it seems to me because there is such
a broad range of data
um and so much of it is unstructured
right there's so little that we can
actually say like
oh i have a i have a finite set of data
and here it is and you can use it uh
in this organized fashion um do you know
not not inside amazon but is there is
there even the idea that someone's
trying to build like a universal
database
to try to solve the the structured data
problem
because it just that seems like such an
overwhelmingly large problem
i think there are there are quite a few
initiatives uh uh focused on that
uh some inside alexa some inside other
large
companies uh some uh
even public efforts and and i think
definitely there is those techniques or
developing those large knowledge bases
or knowledge graphs how they are used
uh constitute one of the
important ways in which alexa tries to
satisfy customer needs right so
especially if you think of
questions that are asked again and again
right the
what is typically called let's say the
have questions or the questions that are
at the top of the distribution um
it makes all the sense in the world to
figure out how to develop the knowledge
resources and to
distill the knowledge in the world that
is essential for
people's needs and deliver that to them
in
slightly let's say less evolved
fashion right by visiting that knowledge
rather than finding the appropriate
information in that knowledge graph
the unstructured the data that my team
is focusing on
is like okay kind of like the long tail
of questions for everything else right
so
i think there is always going to be a
long tail
of questions that customer would want to
ask and to have answers for
and it seems to me that uh
creating the capabilities that can tap
on unstructured data
is the correct approach there to go all
right
okay so so as as alexa kind of came on
and we
we really think more about this this
human machine
interface right because a lot of people
will think of a human machine interfaces
like me typing into a laptop but it's
really it's really not
uh when we talk about human machine
interactions we're really talking about
a way for me to communicate in a natural
way and for the computer or the machine
to be able to understand me
and it really is unlock things right i
control appliances all over my house
i control light switches and can my
garage door and all that kind of stuff
and i just
talk into the air and this all stuff
happens like magic um
from from what you guys are focused on
from your perspective
what makes interacting with an
intelligent device
what makes that information retrieval
that you're working on
what makes that different from like me
typing things into my computer
let me preamble that by by saying that i
think that
alex already does lots of
amazing things it plays music it wakes
you up as you point it out it tells you
the news you can listen to the news on
alexa
and tons and tons of stuff that in many
instances even myself when i joined alex
i didn't know that alexa was so smart
and it knows how to do so many things
having said that i think that
alexa and not only alexa all digital
assistants
i don't think they're that smart
and i think that they are still far from
being able to enable people
interact with the information in the
same way
people interact with each other and also
in the same way people interact with
information
even on a desktop computer okay so so
let me let me maybe break this down into
into a few uh into a few a few
dimensions along which it's a little bit
different right so
when you deal with voice first of all
you kind of need to figure out
there are some errors that come from the
voice which are
typically maybe fewer than the typing
errors that you can
and they're easier to catch typing
errors because you see
already the the words in print and you
can apply tons of algorithms that work a
little bit easier on
context uh yeah then
um understanding it's uh understanding
the
understanding errors right so uh also
the way if you think especially if you
think of um
conversations that you have with a
machine in natural language
um or multi-turning fractions there's
lots more going on there compared to
what people do
and they just issue a sequence of
queries
in their desktop so you use you're much
more conversational you use lots of
ellipses and aphras what linguists call
an afro so the machine kind of needs to
figure
all that out right then the
you have a fairly narrow communication
channel right and you need to
figure out how to use that very wisely
so
should i produce a short answer should i
give a long answer
should i provide a summary if i didn't
understand the question should i try to
clarify the question
should i recommend the follow-up topic
so all those are things that
you kind of need to solve right and the
last one
uh just think a little bit how
many things you can do let's say when
you interact with information
on a desktop today right you research
you bookmark
you you save pages that you go
to them later you cut and paste you
compare alternatives sometimes you spend
weeks trying to figure out where you go
for example for your what to do for your
next vacation i definitely do that
and for sure and then
if you think of digital assistance today
there are no
equivalent let's say behaviors on
assistant uh digital assistants today
and i'm not saying that they need to be
uh by by that i'm not suggesting that
eventually
these capabilities are going to be worse
right
maybe to to pick up an analogy
think of how let's say our listening
habits
have evolved right so at some point we
had records
and then a big innovation
was we could take some of the records
with us
on the road with the walkmans right with
the
cassette the portable cassette players
right
and at some point the next big
innovation was that
you it was okay not to carry just 10
tapes in your bag
you could carry all the music collection
that you have on an
ipod right and the interface there was
very different than the manner in which
you interacted with that music was very
very different
and then you could actually ask alexa
to play a song right so it's not that it
got
worse it actually got better
yeah yeah it remove the friction you
removed all the friction and eventually
by having the voice interface to
playing music our ability to
to kind of satisfy that need just got
better and better over time so from that
perspective i'm saying that i think
digital assistants are still pretty dumb
so we are still in the
middle ages has it come from sure
development
that's an excellent analogy i think as
we look at the progression of these
things i think that we'll
we'll find that more and more going back
to your vacation analogy even
uh i mean i think about this my family
and i uh pre-covered we had booked an
entire trip
i was eight days in hawaii and we were
really looking forward to this this is
the last
i've been to all 49 states hawaii is the
last one uh and i was
i was really looking forward to like
checking that off i'll have been to all
50 u.s states it would be a great trip
uh and then with covet hitting obviously
we had no vacation
and we looked around and we're like
where could we go and so we'd been to
um the beaches of north carolina before
and a lot of it the area there is called
the outer banks
and so we went we found a house a big
big house
right on the beach and we decided
instead of quarantining in our house
at home we'll just quarantine on the
beach what's the difference right we'll
just drive down there and do that
instead but it took a lot of
research and time and finding the right
houses and the right locations and
figuring out what restaurants would be
available and what activities can happen
and i yearned for an opportunity to just
you know ask my assistant i'm going to
stop saying
because i know people in the chat have
said we've set their devices off a few
times
um but i uh being being able to
get that kind of information i mean
think about even with a search engine
today
you go in and you type something in and
you get a list of results and the first
10
aren't at all what you wanted you need
to really dig down and find
the the one thing that you're really
looking for and it's not that it's just
hard with voice it's just hard
uh to be able to funnel down to the data
that you're really looking for
so um it's it's exciting to know that
we're working on these kinds of things
and that that's
uh ultimately something we should see
like music should get a whole lot better
should get a whole lot more intelligent
uh as we move forward so that's that's
exciting thank you
it's a long haul yeah yeah yeah it is a
long haul like you said you've been
working on this for a very long time
um so you're you're also involved in
machine translation efforts though right
um can you explain some of the ways that
customers
are actually benefiting from machine
translation and maybe some of the
science behind it i'd love to get a
little
a little deep into what that means how
it's beneficial
maybe a lot of the viewers may not even
know what that is or how it works so
anything you can share that would be
great
sure so i've been involved with the
machine translation field for
22 years now i think so
that was actually what the company that
i
co-founded the language event so it was
the first company that
brought to market the data-driven
statistical translation
approach to machine translation
that at that time was revolutionary in
the sense that it transitioned from
uh building machine translation systems
by
uh locking into a room 10 linguists for
several years and asking them to
write the rules that explain how to
translate this word or that word
to just looking over their shoulders and
saying okay here are some translated
data that
these human translators have produced
now can we have a machine that
learns automatically how to mimic that
behavior how to take
by looking at examples of work done by
professional translators can we build a
machine that
can given a new sentence that has not
been seen before can we mimic that and
produce
a new translation for that sentence
that is that is good enough and the
field has gone from
as i said people initially writing all
those rules automatically to then
the statistical approach was statistical
methods for doing that and now
the neural techniques are just following
the same data-driven approach it's just
that the techniques that we use to learn
from these examples are
based on neural models so
uh that's kind of the evolution of the
field in a nutshell
very high level now in you you asked
about customer benefits i think
i think machine translation has improved
massively in the last 22 years
and the places where
amazon for example i think it would be
difficult if not impossible to function
without machine translation so
in the area of what is called content
localization so you think of
uh amazon being available not only in
english us or other english-speaking
languages
being available in all the other
countries around the world
uh all the information that needs to be
translated
to enable those customers to access data
in their own languages i think it would
be
impossible to translate the vast amounts
of information
behind the entire amazon
organization using professional
translators
there are just not enough professional
translators on the planet to do
that right i think
other areas where machine translation
now play a significant role
uh customer engagement in call centers
customer chats so in the past
if you lived in germany or in japan and
if you
wanted to have a conversation with a
customer support agent
that customer agent had to speak
japanese for example or had to speak
german
and there are just fewer people who
speak japanese and
fewer people who speak german than
people who speak for example
english so today
lots of those customer support or
customer engagement
are lots of behaviors are happening via
machine translation
um e-discovery i think it's a it's a
it's a big field
uh going from vast amounts of data
available in
multiple languages to drawing insights
um processing all that data
um alexa to certain extent right so
making alexa available in all the
languages
also machine translation plays an
important role
in accelerating the way in which we
deploy alexa across many languages
and so i think those are just a handful
of the
places where machine translation has
fundamentally changed
the world and now you also asked about
the science i think yeah if you could
share
the the the science i think when when
you look at the current
where the field is today improving
accuracy
is something that has been going on for
the last for the last 50 years in
machine translation
and we are not done yet there
so the field still continues to
work on improving the accuracy and that
is is
particularly important for
what is called low density languages
languages that
do not have that much data so if you
look at languages like spanish and
french
there are tens of thousands of
professional translators available in
those languages
billions and billions of words that
those languages
have in parallel data meaning translated
data
produced by professional translators so
it's so let's say building good
translation systems for spanish and
english and french
that are high density languages
just because data is there is much
easier than doing that for
languages that have
very little parallel data
very little very few examples of
human translated data or in some means
is maybe just
spoken language right so some of the
languages have
started to develop a writing system only
recently and to develop systems for
for those uh it's it's uh challenging so
you you mentioned english spanish and
french
um do you do you find those same
parallels for things that don't use the
traditional latin alphabet that we see
um do you do you find that i mean
obviously there's tons of translators
for things like
chinese and japanese or even russian
which uses a cyrillic alphabet
do you do you find that the same is kind
of true there where
languages that are broadly spoken
generally follow the same pattern
or do you find that there maybe are
interesting challenges that
chinese or japanese might present that
things like english and french and
spanish don't
i think it has less to do with the
alphabet or the
whether they use cyrillic or arabic or
chinese or characters or katakana
i think it has less to do with that
and it has more to do with how
divergent the languages are
in terms of the way they structure
information the way they pack
information so
english french spanish
they are pretty much the same language
just different characters different
words
all of them subject verb object
yes some have more morphology but uh
it's um they're much closer than let's
say when you look at
english and japanese or english and
korean
so that poses a little bit more
challenges because lots of the
information
in japanese sentences is only implicit
for example the
so to figure out or to build the
models that figure out that implicit
information or
even more difficult when you translate
into japanese to
figure out how to represent or to pre
implicitly to right to kind of
capture the to transfer the information
it's a little bit more challenging
than just going from french to spanish
or from french to english or vice versa
it's interesting you say that because i
would imagine you and and and folks that
have
backgrounds similar to yours you look at
languages like
french spanish even german uh and
english
and you say those are the same thing but
i will tell you that my
my 16 year old daughter who's taking
spanish would completely disagree with
you
uh and i think that i think most people
would but i can see when you look at it
from a pattern matching perspective
uh from a machine learning perspective
it's much easier to identify
those kinds of languages versus things
that use different structures i know
justin jeffers who's on my team
is is pretty fluent in japanese as well
as english
and he tried to explain to me once just
how the sentence structure works and how
you have to think about rearranging
um the language entirely and it is quite
different and so it's
uh it's interest i don't think most
people get an opportunity to look at
languages the way that you're describing
them so i think
that's awesome that you were able to
bring that up thank you
uh heart we're running short on time we
actually have six minutes left
uh and i have a whole list of questions
that i really wanted to get through with
you here
so there's one thing i really want to
touch on um i know we've talked a little
bit about nlp
and machine learning and and things like
that but you you've actually published a
book on
uh some of these topics it's called the
theory of practice
theory and practice of discourse parsing
and summarization can you tell me about
your book i'd love to know more about
what that went into i've written a book
myself but i want to know about yours
oh my goodness you did your your
research
yeah so that's uh that's a book that i i
published
by elaborating a little bit more on my
phd thesis so
the uh the book is essentially
built on a premise that a text is more
than a collection of sentences
so um the same way let's say a sentence
is more than a collection of words
right and and that's something that is
very intuitive for
all of us uh to when
when you when you read the when you read
documents sometimes you say yeah this
sentence is just a word salad or
this document it may be it is possible
that sentences
well every single sentence is good but
when you put them together
it can still be an incomprehensible
document right
and if you don't believe that you can
just take a text and shuffle the
sentences and
it's a big mess right so the book was
about
um how the the
book developed uh formalism that
kind of explained what would make
uh a text how
that would formalize the the underlying
hidden structure of
of uh coherent texts so
that's interesting the the cool thing if
you if you manage to formalize it
at that level right from a mathematical
and from a computer science perspective
then you can do things like you can ask
yourself
algorithmic questions you can say how
many interpretations
these course interpretations can i have
for a particular text
and you can build the whole three
structures
discourse structures for text and you
can understand text at the very
different level that
uh you understand them when you look at
them just as a simple sequence of
sentences so for example you can say you
know this text actually has
two main arguments and presents two
big arguments in contrast and this one
here is the core idea and now here is
something a part of the text that
elaborates on that idea right
so think of that kind of recursively
across the entire text
and then once you once you have that
understanding then you can
do a bunch of stuff with it you can uh
for example determine whether texts are
well written or badly written
from a discourse perspective which is
something that
i collaborated with colleagues from
educational testing services and that
got incorporated into software that does
automated
essay scoring and provides feedback to
students
who learn how to write or you can build
the summarization system so
once you manage to to really formalize
it
mathematically and once you manage have
algorithms for that you can also develop
quite a bit of applications quite a few
applications
and that's what that book was very very
cool all right so
we have we have three minutes left and i
i want to wrap up with something at the
end so
um you've been in amazon almost four
years
what's what's one launch or improvement
that you've worked on that you're the
most proud of
um something that maybe improved
customers experience with alexa or
something like that
well i think the
i thought that question also uh when
talking to other scientists that asked
me
daniel what's the paper that you're most
proud of and
every single time i thought about that i
i realized
that i'm not proud of anything or or
or in in put it differently every single
time i write the paper or every single
time we launch
the product i'm super excited and i
think that's the most amazing thing that
has happened in the history of mankind
that's good and you're feeling i feel
like that for about
a few days and after a few days i
i i'm like oh my god but if i was just a
tiny bit smarter i could have presented
or i could have built a
a better paper sure or in the case of a
service
if uh if we were a little bit smarter
the service would have done
something else so in general
when i look back i'm i'm i'm happy with
the work that i've done but they cannot
point to anything as oh well that paper
is awesome or that service is awesome so
i end up being a little bit embarrassed
in some sense
oh my goodness look at that paper how
poor it is now when i look at it 20
years later look at
the service it can be improved in so
many ways it sounds like
it sounds like you know exactly what
it's like to be a software developer
uh i i will finish my code today and i
will open it back up tomorrow and i'll
be like
who wrote all this garbage this is
terrible
uh i know exactly what you're describing
i think a lot of the people that are
watching have probably had a very
similar feeling
where you're proud of it for a very
brief fleeting moment and then
it's gone i i can't tell you the number
of times that i've gotten into code that
i personally wrote
only to say why would someone do it this
way
this doesn't make any sense to me and
it's only because because we've grown
right we've learned
we've taken the learnings that we had
there and applied it to new things i
think that's
that's outstanding so i mentioned
earlier uh the kdd 2020 conference
that's happening
um i know that you've got a few people
from your organization that are
participating in that this week right
yeah actually there are quite a few
people from all across
amazon i'm also giving a talk today at
kdb i invited speakers there so
but what i would encourage you or
anyone else who's listening to this
interview there's quite a bit more about
the
amazon participation in kdd on the
amazon science website so
that's a website that has quite a bit of
information about tons of issues or tons
of problems
specific to science at amazon and i
encourage you
it's a really hard url to remember it's
amazon.science
so for all of you that are like i gotta
google that and find it
amazon.science will get you there uh
we've done some good jobs with our urls
actually if you're looking for an
opportunity
amazon.jobs is the place you go so
amazon.science is the face you'll find
all about what they're doing at kdd this
week
and a number of other science
initiatives that's where they really
spend a lot of time focusing on
what the interesting scientific approach
and research that's happening at amazon
is going on so that's uh that's
fantastic so daniel i can't thank you
enough we uh we are right at time
i can't thank you enough for being here
today this has been fantastic
thank you very much jeff it was a
pleasure so thank you guys all for
tuning in
uh just as a side note we have another
stream here on this channel in about 30
minutes
we're going to be talking about alexa
conversations uh and how that works and
some of the people that
uh put it together are actually going to
be here joining me and justin jeffers so
please join us here in about a half an
hour
but with that daniel i'll say thank you
so much again for being here thank you
everyone for tuning in and we will see
you all again very soon
bye-bye